desde mi perspectiva el momento que
plasma esta fusión entre el hombre y el
arte es el que plasmó miguel ángel en la
capilla sixtina es el momento en que el
hombre es hombre y comienza a crear ese
momento divino nos marca como seres
humanos de ahí en adelante la sociedad
va dando saltos cuánticos a través de la
historia
a mí la pintura me ha traído grandes
satisfacciones pero también me hayan
llevado a transitar por caminos oscuros
y algunas veces he pensado en dejarla
estaba yo en uno de esos momentos
oscuros cuando tuve mi primer llamado
digo llamado pero es como un llamado de
atención la muerte de mi primer nieta yo
había oído una frase que se me hacía muy
trillada como una metáfora perder el eje
y decía yo que es perder el eje hasta me
echó cabeza frase que utilizaba la gente
y ahí yo perdí el eje perdí el trazo
perdí la composición perdí todo
al final de ese túnel oscuro siempre
estuvo un lienzo en blanco esperándome
en ese momento volvía a renacer pasa un
tiempo aproximadamente unos dos años y
me dan un diagnóstico médico no muy
favorable
pero curiosamente pasada la sorpresa
y los médicos que me atendieron y me
atienden hasta hoy en día
eran grandes amantes del arte entonces
yo pienso que fui elegida me
comprendieron como artista comprendieron
mi problemática y a pesar del caos de la
situación de dos operaciones todo lo que
esto implica y conlleva
las palabras de los médicos siempre
fueron
vamos a tratar de que en un mes tú ya
estás creando
y en ese momento ante esas palabras
concretas
yo contesté me conteste a mí misma
una pregunta que tantas veces me había
hecho cuál es la función del arte en la
sociedad motivar esta motivación a mí me
sirvió
para volver a crear volver a pintar y
así
en ese motor es energía darle una patada
en el trasero al cáncer
de ahí en adelante seguir trabajando y
para mí todos los que transitamos por
este mundo del arte
la óptica nos cambia vemos todo desde un
punto de vista diferente todos los que
creamos arte o entendemos el arte se nos
abre todo un panorama
entonces como les había dicho desde las
etapas primigenias del arte pues el arte
ha estado toda la vida con nosotros
ustedes se preguntarán cómo se sabe esto
cómo sabemos cuál es arte desde qué
momento
por ejemplo los hombres de las cavernas
ya trataban ellos de transmitirnos algo
todo esto lo dejaron plasmado en piedra
pero los hombres de las cavernas
cumplieron una función ritual como
chamanes y también ejercían un poder
jerárquico sobre los animales como les
dije todo esto lo plasmaron ellos en
piedra porque porque ellos así lograban
capturar el espíritu del animal
entonces estas pinturas rupestres que
tienen aproximadamente una data de unos
40 mil años no nos vamos aquí a meter en
honduras porque hay unas que han datado
más con más antigüedad pero ahorita
vamos a las que conocemos
y ahí ya vemos que un aproximadamente un
30 por ciento de ellas ya fueron hechas
por artistas geniales
son obras que se diferencian de las
demás son obras que podrían haber sido
hechas por un pintor genial como picasso
son obras que tienen trazo perspectiva
expresión color una prueba de ello es la
cueva de altamira en españa' que es
llamada la capilla sixtina del arte
moderno digo del arte rupestre perdón
tenemos el axioma de que el arte más el
ser humano nos iguala renacimiento el
renacimiento no sólo fue un periodo del
arte todas las civilizaciones antiguas
los sumerios los ak dios los hititas los
griegos los romanos los olmecas los
mayas las aztecas
vivieron creando arte el arte era
fundamental fundamental para ellos
porque era parte de la función que tenía
como educativo sociológico y político
entonces para todas las culturas siempre
el arte ha estado presente en nuestras
vidas y el periodo del renacimiento por
ejemplo que para mí es mi periodo
favorito porque considero que es uno de
los períodos más ricos
poderosos y que nos dio grandes genios
de la historia del arte para mí es un
periodo único porque porque ya los
griegos por ejemplo ellos ya sabían que
eran admirados por los hombres de su
presente y serían homenajeados por los
hombres del futuro ellos ya sabían que
estaban creando filosofía literatura
gran arquitectura a todo pero el único
momento en que el ser humano es
consciente de vivir en una época
determinada
ese periodo es en el renacimiento es un
periodo único para mí en la historia del
arte y así como en el renacimiento estas
civilizaciones fueron civilizaciones
resilientes fueron civilizaciones que a
pesar de los grandes problemas que
tenían volvían a renacer así hay un
término también que se llama resiliencia
geográfica y es la capacidad de las
comunidades y ecosistemas de absorber
perturbaciones sin alterar
significativamente sus características
de estructura y funcionalidad y una vez
pasando estas perturbaciones pueden
volver a su estado original
yo pienso que todos lo podemos lograr yo
siempre he creído que el arte más
trabajo genera pueblos cultos
y esa es la raíz de todas las
civilizaciones las grandes
civilizaciones no se hicieron solas fue
cuestión de trabajo y de apostarle a la
cultura porque porque la cultura
comprende nuestro lenguaje nuestro
vestido la arquitectura comprende todo
lo que somos los seres humanos yo soy
artista plástica yo le aposté a la
ciudad yo aquí tengo mi taller aquí vivo
digo salgo mucho a trabajar pero aquí
estamos de base y de aquí salen mis
lienzos a varias partes del mundo
entonces para mí es algo sumamente
importante que todos creamos en nuestra
ciudad
que hemos tenido errores errores en el
manejo de ciertas
cosas entre el estado o los individuos
que somos pero creo que entre todos
podemos generar algo bueno la capacidad
que tenían estas civilizaciones antiguas
de renacer las vemos en todos los
pueblos nosotros lo que tenemos ahorita
que hacer es innovar crear nuevos
paradigmas artísticos cambiar yo sé que
ahorita al cambiar nuestro entorno
nosotros por ejemplo hace unos 34 años
la ciudad de coatzacoalcos era una
ciudad calmada transitábamos libremente
eso cambio cambió nuestro diálogo porque
porque ahorita tenemos que cuidarnos más
pero básicamente aunque la ciudad de
coatzacoalcos ha perdido un poco su
brillo la ciudad sigue ahí la ciudad
está viva y creo que juntos podemos
lograr
y crear bases para nuevos proyectos para
juntos todos renacer con la ciudad
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]